so hi everybody uh my name is Benjamin
Walters I'm a senior scientist at
Genentech
um uh in the department of biochemical
and cellular pharmacology I'd like to
thank Thermo for inviting me to give you
this seminar today where I'll get to
share with you a little bit of my
experience so far at genintech using
hydrogen Exchange
so I thought I'd Begin by telling you a
little bit about how I got into this
because I didn't actually think that I
was going to become you know an expert
in protein hydrogen exchange when I
started graduate school actually I went
to graduate school I was interested in
how does a protein fold how does it do
it in a biologically relevant time scale
there are these two theories one about a
protein folding funnel and another about
this this pathway theory that it
actually existed for a long time and the
problem was there wasn't really any good
Technologies to measure this with the
with the level of resolution needed to
say something about how the process
worked
I ended up going
um to the lab of of of
uh Dr Walter Englander that you see over
here on the right and uh and I quickly
learned that if I wanted to study
protein folding experimentally I was
going to need to learn about a
technology called hydrogen exchange or
amid hydrogen exchange one of my
favorite quotes from Walter was that you
can learn everything you ever wanted to
know and everything you didn't about
protein folding with hydrogen Exchange
activity in a protein doesn't come from
a rock it comes from the movement in the
protein and so we need to understand
these things in order to understand
protein activity if you're more
interested in protein folding that's not
really the the focus of my talk today uh
you're more than welcome to have a look
at this paper it's actually a really
good paper that summarizes a lot of
Walter's work on protein folding
um and it was published in pnes in 2014.
I'll briefly tell you a little bit about
at least my takeaways from working with
Walter and this really fun experiment
I'm going to kind of walk into hydrogen
exchange first starting out very
conceptually and telling you about an
experiment called kinetic pulse labeling
in this experiment basically you can
think of it as we start with the Protein
that's unfolded and we dilute it into
folding conditions we have this stuff HX
spray paint and when we spray it on the
system for a very small amount of time
at a certain time Point anything that's
folded resists getting painted anything
that's not folded gets painted okay and
then we can chop the protein up into
little bits and we can look at what got
painted and what didn't get painted and
we can say hey was this piece folded
when I did the pulse or not in doing so
we can learn a little bit about the
order of events in protein folding and
actually in my dissertation that that
these are kind of the main points of my
of a lot of work in in my dissertation I
was trying to understand how this
protein maltose binding protein actually
made its way to the native state
um some of the important raw data is
being shared over here on the right
where this is folding time uh the time
until I gave it the pulse and the
fraction of the population that uh that
didn't get painted
and what you can see here is that
there's a fraction that seems to resist
getting painted a lot earlier than the
others
it turned out that was because the
protein formed an intermediate
um within about nine seconds and then it
took some time to shake out what we
think of as potentially misfolded States
or something that happened in this this
stage called the collapse which I'm not
going to talk a little a lot about right
now but once it started to shake that
out it could then fold this little green
piece and then proceed to fold the gray
and the red in time uh this this this
explains how proteins fold in a
biologically relevant time scale they do
it because they don't all have to fold
at once they fold in subglobal units
um it was really interesting to note
that uh there are three mutations known
in in multisbinding protein shown here
that prevent the protein from
effectively folding and if a pathway
hypothesis is true
this makes a whole lot of sense because
if you can't get through this
intermediate you can't make it to the
native state it stands in contrast to
folding funnels
and the only way that you can get this
information is by an experiment like
hydrogen exchange which can show you
that at nine seconds certain pieces are
folded and other pieces definitively are
not
how did that experiment work
well we have to look a little bit the
fundamentals of hydrogen Exchange in
order to see how this works this is a
really old way of of writing kind of the
hydrogen exchange reaction and we're
going to focus on the amide the reason
that we're going to focus on the amide
is because it exchanges at just the
right rate when it's exposed to water so
all of the other protons in the protein
are exchanging but they're either going
too fast or too slow the amide exchanges
at just the right rate and what I mean
by that is is this chemical exchange
rate
so we can look at the chemistry here the
chemistry depends heavily on ph it
depends on the donor PKA which is in
which is affected by the sequence and it
depends on the temperature
you see down here with ph we have a
minimum at about pH 2.5 this is really
great because it allows us to
effectively Slow Down The Exchange
reaction so that we can measure it we
can slow it down to about one percent
per minute or if we get up to say pH you
know five six seven eight even into the
higher ranges The Exchange drops down to
the milliseconds time scale
and so you can measure everything from
you know very slow opening reactions to
things that are actually quite fast
um by just simply modifying the pH
now why does it tell us about protein
Dynamics how is this a protein Dynamics
experiment
well as it turns out
um that's because uh there's structural
physics involved
when there's a hydrogen bond to the
proton it cannot exchange it is
precluded it is protected and so the
only time that it's available to
exchange the only time that it's
available to go at this rate constant
depends on the structural physics of the
opening and closing reactions and sure
if you're you know it tends it tends to
be the case that amidst that are exposed
to solvent uh spend less time in
hydrogen bonds than amides who are
buried in the center of a protein and
this is given rise to a level of solvent
accessibility I like to think about it
as hydrogen bonds
and how we actually do the experiment
how we actually carry it out and this
experiment's a little bit different than
the spray painting experiment but
fundamentally it would be done the same
way after the quench step and the native
state experiment we have a folded
protein that we just diluted into detail
this is the experiment that you'll be
probably more familiar with too and then
we take this Protein that's diluted into
into d2o and we watch it slowly as it
exchanges as all these amids go from H
to D
and they're dependent on the stability
of the structure or the stability of the
hydrogen bonds by dropping the pH or
quenching we can then digest the protein
after we've labeled it separate its
peptides and then measure how much mass
they've taken on with respect to time so
this is done after we've done the
labeling experiment and then by piecing
together all the peptides that we've
measured we can see that structure or
you know a significant standoff from the
kinetic exchange rate is observed as we
start to get into residues 11 12 13 14
15 16 but not before so residues one to
ten don't show us much of an effect and
in this way we can start to see okay
structure stable structure exists in
these sites
you know conceptually that experiment is
is working like this you know we have
the protein we put it into d2o slowly
all of these black spots which represent
hydrogens are going to go and exchange
themselves for deuterium and then we're
going to be able to see where it is by
chopping the protein up into into
different peptides we can look at the
thermodynamics by looking at the
standoff how far does how
long did it take to see the uh to see
the the equivalent impulse
um On Any Given peptide that's going to
tell us something about the
thermodynamics
this paper really goes into detail about
that I'd recommend it if you're
interested
um in the in the structural biophysics
of this experiment
um but an experiment that you've seen
done very often
um is epitope mapping where
we're basically adding a binding partner
um and and looking at the perturbation
effect that The Binding partner had I
just want to stress though that
everything in Native HX is kind of a
comparison experiment either we're
comparing how long it took to exchange
between the chemical exchange rate our
Theory and what we observed in the
experiment to tell us about structural
thermodynamics or we're looking at the
difference in time to exchange so in a
peptide that's affected by The Binding
partner
um you know it might change the exchange
Trace from say the blue line to the
green line or maybe from the grain line
it's the black line
you know I wanted to show you one quick
example that you can read more about
they kind of wraps everything together
on the native state end
um where where we were actually able to
show that the Affinity difference
between a wild type antibody and what's
called the yte mutant was was driven by
the structural thermodynamics of the two
proteins before they bound their
receptor
so how does that whole thing work well
basically this is the the receptor is
called the fcrn receptor and it's really
neat because the Affinity of the
antibody for fcrn only exists at low ph
and high pH it has no affinity
um when you look at the Crystal
structures of the YT mutant and the wild
type uh bound to fcr and there was
really no discernible differences
between them uh the the the the sites of
mutation weren't really making any extra
contacts with fcrn
um and then if you look at the Crystal
structures the Unbound State you saw a
very similar thing and they're basically
superimposable there was no there's no
real differences so you couldn't explain
using structure
um why did the yte mutant have higher
affinity for fcra
and so it turned out that um that that
the affinity for fcrn of the yte mutant
was really driven by uh the
destabilization that occurred and was
compensated for by binding to fcr at low
PH if you'd like to read more about this
story um we we summarized it um in JBC a
few years back um but it's a really good
example about how structural
thermodynamics can be used even in that
mapping experiments
um but you know you might be asking at
this point well how does protein
Dynamics impact the industry I mean a
lot of this seems like basic science so
far I mean it's great to understand all
this stuff but the yte mutant but you
know I think the Salient message there
was that we needed Dynamics to really
understand the picture
and you know I think as it turns out
protein Dynamics really leads to all the
emergent activity that we see in the lab
whether it's aggregation
um which is affecting shelf life of our
products or whether it's the mechanism
of action why is it that this compound
binding in a certain location
is silencing this protein or why is it
that that when we made this one change
to this compound it stopped binding it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense to me
well a lot of this is because of the
Dynamics of the protein and we're
missing that picture if we're just
focusing on the structure
so you know I called this presentation
running the gamut because I I
fortunately you know I've been at
genintech for a little while and I've
had the opportunity to work on a lot of
different problems throughout early
stage and late stage research and
Discovery so I thought I'd tell you a
selection of three of these problems
today uh and and try to proverbially run
the gamut here um and and tell you uh at
least a selection of one from each side
of the of the game
um research and development and so I'll
start actually in early research where a
project team has a Target and they're
just looking for a foothold they're
looking for a way to begin
we actually screened a much larger set
of compounds but I'm showing you up to
maybe 10 here four compound results are
being shown here shaded onto the protein
the red shading is showing regions where
we saw differences when we compared the
two experiments bound and Unbound that
all of these compounds are sharing a
similar region
um this little area here
but then they're all also showing us
some unique signatures as well
and so we are getting
um you know like this one is having a
very large allosteric effect maybe
that's important maybe it's not
um can we distinguish between allosteric
changes and maybe a Second Sight binding
well what's interesting and what this
and what this plot shows us here is that
if the changes that we're seeing on the
protein are induced by a single binding
site uh as we titrate through the KD of
that binding site all of these changes
should move together gradually uh back
to the Unbound state
and so actually that's exactly what you
see in peptides 82 to 97 or even 168 to
174. I mean it regardless of the
magnitudes of the change the shift
between Unbound and fully bound
happening at about the same rate at
every single peptide that tells us that
it's it's allosteric
we can also increase the throughput by
doing a selected time point now we don't
know a priori which time point we need
to sample but what we learned by doing
an initial set of experiments was that
in these two peptides here which are
affected by every single compound that
we tested if we sample for 100 minutes
we're going to kind of get the maximum
of this effect
um and so the idea then would be that we
could then Screen through a large number
of compounds sampling with a single time
point
I mean and then we could Bend compounds
with with similar uh mechanisms of
action as deduced by the effects that we
saw by HX and then another added
Advantage getting back to some of the
thermodynamics I was just talking about
because remember it's not just basic
science there's some relationship
between the energetic consequences of
binding uh the protection factor that we
talked about and the Affinity of the
compounds as you can see here compounds
with higher Affinity tend to produce
larger protection factors
this is very interesting and potentially
very useful in the future because you
could screen on the basis of protection
factors
it's also useful because you'll expect
to find the largest protection Factor at
the site of interaction and so using
protection factors sometimes you can
also try to kind of separate out between
allosteric change and direct effect
to summarize this experiment um uh the
small molecule hit validation you know
we we gain speed with reduced ambiguity
and that's really valuable because you
know information is critical to making
good decisions especially in early stage
research being able to see the
difference between a non-specific binder
and something that's binding
specifically to a location is very
meaningful
because it could allow us to pursue the
correct lead molecule
it also can allow us to start
understanding the molecular attributes
of the system and connect the target
design profile to that
as we move into the later stages of
research things like mechanisms of
action become much more important really
being able to detail the epitope becomes
important for say legal filings so I'm
going to tell you a really fun story uh
that spanned a couple of years here uh
where we were where where the quest was
to inhibit beta-tryptase and I got to
work with a very talented team of
individuals
um Henry Mullen is the lead author on
both of these papers that summarize our
work
um but you know what I would say that
hydrogen exchange here not only led to
an epitope differentiation but I think
it led to structural information because
it allowed us to to generate hypotheses
and then test them in the lab
you know briefly the way that beta trip
case works it's involved in asthma
um it's a lot like trypsin a little bit
different uh and trypsin you start off
as a zymogen cleavage allows for uh
pro-domain insertion which leads to
activation of trypsin as you can see
here and that's really just because
you've changed the orientation of just a
few residues here in the active site the
catalytic Triad
okay now if we take this model and think
about it in the context of tryptase it's
very similar we have to have the pro
domain inserted but there's kind of some
extra pieces over here on trip case and
in order to stabilize and so that this
active site can become active uh you
basically need to touch your Mirage
whereby uh these additional loopy pieces
are going to reach over and interact
with a neighboring subunit
um to create a tetrimmer like this where
all of the active sites Point into the
tetramer center
this creates kind of a therapeutic
challenge because the active site can't
be hit by endogenous protease inhibitors
like anti-one antitrypsin simply because
the active site's not accessible
this project team
ended up with a few lead molecules
um uh three are being shown here and I'm
going to focus on two of them
the plot to the right shows you the
effects of uh inhibiting tryptase
activity with the full length antibody
or IGG
which is shown depicted down at the
bottom
it has an FC domain and two Fab domains
with a hinge that connects the Fabs to
the FC or as Fabs only so meaning we can
clip them at the hinge and release these
Fabs
the two things that I want you to focus
on here are what happens to the green
versus the red Trace when we clip off
the FC domain
foreign
in the case of the green antibody
it requires the full length molecule to
inhibit
when we produce the Fab it stops working
altogether
it also has this interesting thing
called The Hook effect where it stops
inhibiting in high concentrations I'm
not going to focus on that here
in contrast the red antibody 31a it
works whether or not it's a Fab or
full-length antibody
now this wouldn't be too puzzling in and
of itself I mean different antibodies
work in different ways
but these antibodies compete for the
same epitope
so
why
do they have such different mechanisms
of action
and then a secondary question why are we
having such a tough time with Crystal
formation so the project team could not
get a crystal structure in this case
they were really struggling
they came to me with with some material
and I said yeah I'll do some hydrogen
exchange here
um the hydrogen exchange results are
colored onto the tetramer here to the
right
um uh 31a is shown in yellow and e104 is
shown in blue you can see why they would
compete with one another there are
residues that are in common
there are also residues that are
different this blue patterning goes down
here and over here
um and you know in looking at these
results we started to think about okay
well
you know perhaps it's uh simply a matter
of steric clash maybe the anthem maybe
maybe 31a Fabs sterically clash with one
another if they both bind uh like this
and so there would be two that would
that would be coming kind of on into the
page down onto the subunits and then two
coming up from the bottom
you know maybe they sterically clash and
that forces these things apart and then
we thought you know in contrast this
looks like this is a little bit more to
the side of the antibody here so maybe
maybe maybe this antibody kind of binds
a little bit more kicked over to the
side
and so maybe without the hinge present
you could actually have four Fabs bound
to the same um um trip taste tetramer
and then maybe in the 31a case uh you
couldn't do that and that's why 31a led
to dissociation as a Fab and not e104
but then you know as a quick aside
before I tell you uh the answer to this
question why did one work as a Fab and
one one not
um there was always this background
question can any of this information
help us figure out how to get a crystal
well as it turned out it did
um and I'm giving you this slide this is
directly from uh Henry uh who is the
crystallographer on this team and he
tells me that the hydrogen exchange
results directly led to him uh figuring
out how to do this so the green and blue
shaded regions uh show you residues that
were affected by binding of the antibody
in the presence of 31a the green is
showing you the ones that uh were
consistent with the crystal structure so
all the regions that that were seen by
HX and then also contacting in the
crystal structure versus the blue or the
allosteric changes seen by HX that were
not observed in the crystal structure
eventual
no so I kind of I kind of blew the story
because I'm talking about the crystal
structure before I'm telling you whether
or not we were able to generate it but
it wouldn't be a very good story if we
weren't able to get it
um the whole idea that that Henry had
was that he was looking at the system
and said okay well the tetramer is
required because the monomer can't be
crystallized
and if we can't generate a tetramer
bound to a Fab because the Fabs cause
dissociation we're never going to be
able to get a crystal and this is
because of the dynamic instability of
beta triptase in this region it needs to
actually form this tetramer or it's very
unstable
foreign
X though indicated that there were no
real changes in the active site that all
the changes that were due to the
antibody binding were away from the
active site and so Henry thought to
himself
I wonder
you know usually making a complex larger
is bad for crystallography but I wonder
if adding a uh you know an active site
inhibitor uh might actually work in this
situation maybe we could use uh the
soybean tripase inhibitor or soybean
trypsin inhibitor excuse me to bind to
the active site stabilize this region of
the molecule maybe this will allow us to
get a crystal
so in Henry's words he never would have
tried this without the hydrogen exchange
data suggesting that there would be no
competition between the STI and uh and
the Fab and in any event
um he attributes the fact that he saw
this HX data to being able to generate
this crystal structure which was
incredibly useful because this became
our lead candidate once we had the
crystal structure we were actually able
to start doing some modeling to see that
yeah it made a lot of sense it probably
was that
um that their steric clashing between uh
regions of neighboring Fabs bound to the
same subunits that were causing
um Association in the case of 31a as a
Fab only
um and so and so Henry thought of an
experiment that he might be able to do
to kind of test this hypothesis
um if e104 requires the full length
antibody because of the way that it's
bound to the Fabs you know in opposite
say of 31a which is able to get steric
clashing uh between the Fab domains
themselves then maybe if we elongate the
hinge a little bit we would relieve the
tension
um that is actually leading to
dissociation and the molecule is not
working if we so so in other words if we
elongate the hinge we can achieve the
same thing as if we clipped off or if we
clipped away the hinge altogether
um could this basically be the reason a
hinge plier
well the short story here is that yeah
actually that's exactly what we observed
in the lab as Henry made these hinge
mutants where he extended the length of
the hinge
we were able to basically abrogate the
effect of the full-length antibody
um
sequentially at with with longer and
longer hinges less and less and less
inhibition
so there's actually a paper out on this
right now and it's really it's really
fascinating because there's a lot of
different tools that came together to do
this experiment but the initial hydrogen
exchange results
actually suggested that this might be
the case
you know I think this power or that this
the story really demonstrates kind of
some power of hydrogen exchange when
used in combination with other methods
um it led us to a hypothesis about the
mechanism of action
um it enabled a crystallization strategy
uh for a project that had been trying to
get a crystal for more than a year
um and it agreed with all other
structural methods yet it took a lot
less time this was actually the first
case where we demonstrated allosteric
mechanism
um to be how an antibody in the genie
repertoire worked and this was actually
the first cryo-em structure that
Genentech ever ever uh produced
um and it was of tryptace uh bound to
the e104 V1 Fabs so because of all this
data and and the epitopes you know we
decided to to try to crystallize four
tetramers or excuse me four Fabs bound
to the same Ketchum or an e104 and that
eventually led to a high resolution
crystal structure
um but this just kind of shows you how
the hydrogen exchange regions did really
paint a good picture of the epitope
last but not least I'd like to share
with you a story
um that is very different than the first
two it's on the other side of the
spectrum we're going to go into
development now and we're going to get
back to protein folding actually
and to tell you a little bit about
transportation and mechanical stress
um some of you might not realize it but
proteins are sensitive to Mechanical
stress like simply shaking the solution
that they're suspended in you can see
here a picture of two vials one has been
mechanically shaken and the other is the
control you can see Aggregates clearly
informed in the mechanically shaking
sample the control has nothing
how could hydrogen exchange tell us
about this
well there's a a a really interesting
paper written by a colleague of mine two
colleagues of mine at the time uh
Danielle liske and uh Ian she
um and Ian was focused on this whole
idea that it's it it's it's all about
the air water interface that the air
water interface
um leads to these or
destabilizes an antibody and the air
water interface is basically coated with
antibodies because it's hydrophobic
um
what he found was that in molecules that
have you know worse aggregation problems
upon shaking stress
uh that that they tend to have a greater
surface pressure
um than antibodies that have a lower
problem and the surface pressure uh
seemed to suggest to him that you know
perhaps there's even you know some
degree of unfolding that's happening at
the interface that he was able to
measure
anyways he came up with the metric where
he said okay High uh High change in in
surface access uh with respect to time
is going to cause an antibody to
aggregate it's going to be associated
with antibiotic aggregation and a low
change in this pressure with respect to
time is going to be a limited
aggregation this is a great tool for
screening then to detect whether or not
we're going to have a problem with our
antibody
um but it doesn't quite tell us why why
does a certain antibody have more of a
problem and another antibody have less
of a problem with the same shaking
stress under the same conditions
I should have shown that a little bit
earlier but that shows the correlation
between the the change in the pressure
and the aggregation uh you should check
out this paper it's really fascinating
the tools that they use to make these
measurements
um so Chumley and I chomley was working
with me she's a graduate student in in
David vice's lab
um and and we we had this hypothesis
that basically
um at the air water interface some
antibodies are unfolding faster than
others
and uh the ones that are unfolding
faster or more than others then over
time I uh will start to aggregate uh
under shaking stress you're basically
constantly turning over this interface
over and over and over again antibody
the the sample will repartition to the
interface incredibly fast
um and over time more and more molecules
are unfolded over time they're not
having time to refold and so they're
aggregating that was our hypothesis now
if this is true we should be able to
test it with hydrogen Exchange
so the experiment being shown over here
on the right should be able to take the
antibody get it into d2o by gel
filtration uh and then compare an
agitated sample to a non-agitated sample
take time points quench them and measure
them by mass spectrometry we should
hopefully be able to see the antibodies
who have bigger aggregation problems uh
are going to take in more deuterium and
the ones that have less are going to
take in less
what you're seeing here is is actually
um uh peptides from two different
antibodies uh map Alpha and map beta in
this case
um
I can't tell you the exact names of
these antibodies but what I can tell you
is that um
this one Matt beta will be a lot worse
than map Alpha if we don't protect it
with polysorbate polysorbate is
something I'm not going to get too much
into right now but the idea with
polysorbate is that it coats the air
water interface
um it's it's it's amphipipilic and so
it's going to stick its hydrophobic
Tails uh up into the air and and it's
going to basically mimic bulk water from
the perspective of antibody and so the
antibody doesn't see the interface
um well we found out that that the
effects that we were seeing so we were
getting increased Exchange in map beta
um
as compared to say mab Alpha we're
showing the bit you know the largest
change uh in Signal here the the red
peptide on the left and then the same
red peptide to the right
um You can see that basically uh map
Alpha which gives us no change in
turbidity at all
um gives us only a very slight
destabilization
um when it's when it's agitated and that
both of these antibodies basically are
fully controlled with polysorbate 20.
now polysorbate 20 has blessings and
curses I mean polysorbate 20 is in
almost all products that are almost all
parenteral products
um because you know sub-visible
particles are really important you don't
want a sub-visible particles and things
that you're injecting into people the
polysorbate can degrade and then lead to
sub-visible particles on its own so what
we would ideally be able to do is
engineer a molecule to be resistant to
these effects
um and and being able to see locally
what is the first region to unfold at
the interface might allow us to go in
and make selective mutations in these
regions of the molecule to make it uh
less sensitive to mutation
what was interesting is that there was
there was I think I showed you a third
molecule back here yeah map gamma right
here sorry that I skipped over this
quickly
um but you could see mab Alpha is
basically showing us no difference Matt
beta is is showing us a little bit of
game of gain and turbidity whereas map
gamma is really bad so we looked at the
difference between Alpha and beta but
what about Gamma why I mean is is map
gamma going to be that much worse than
Alpha and beta
yes and as it turns out it's it's it's
fascinating to me somebody who's
interested in the kinetics of hydrogen
exchange and interested in hydrogen
exchange theory and I'm showing you you
know differences in what's called ex1
kinetics where basically every unfolding
reaction leads to a labeling reaction uh
versus versus the X2 kinetics over here
on the left and these are kind of
details but the point is here the whole
antibody lit up
um this molecule is basically unfolding
at the interface hardly any of it is
unaffected in conclusion what it means
is that well we can we can directly
explain why mad gamma is aggregating
more than mad Alpha and beta we can even
show where it's unfolding worse
um and and this you know hopefully in
the future will give us a utility in
protein engineering to potentially
engineer out these liabilities from our
products without actually having to add
things like polysorbate to protect them
and so with that I'd just like to um
acknowledge uh the people who are
involved um in in in the work that I was
able to share with you this morning
um the trip case team over here on the
left Bob Henry Claudio James and tank
shank check out these two manuscripts if
you're interested in learning more
um the mechanical stress study was done
uh with chamoli gamage uh uh and uh her
PhD uh Professor Dave advice and
University of Kansas
and Jasper Lynn and boys and Ian she
and then the hit the lead work was
actually done
um working a little bit with jamily and
uh and and uh this team here from BCP
um and so with that um I'd like to thank
you for the opportunity to present and I
look forward to talking with you in the
open Panel session